20 million Soviet citizens died at his hands for a quarter of a century.
He ruled his huge Ambar with a ruthless iron.
Fist terror was his modus operandi while he was alive,
no one,
not even his closest family members were safe.
Yet at his passing,
he was mourn as the savior of his people.
In this week's buying graphics,
we uncover the terrible truth about Joseph Stalin.
A single death is a tragedy.
1 million deaths is a statistic.
The man who would come to be known as Joseph Stalin was born in the small
Georgian town of glory.
At the time,
Georgia was part of the imperial Russian empire.
His date of birth was December the 18th 1878 stolen father of a salary and zero
cash villi.
It was also known as bay,
so he was a shoemaker,
runs also an alcoholic,
or you spend much of his time away from home producing footwear for the Russian
army.
On his rare appearances at home,
he would beat his wife and son,
Stalin's mother,
Catherine,
Rena,
Aussie meted out punishments on the boy that was generally protective.
Often Stalin only learn to speak Russian when he was nine years old and
throughout his entire life.
He never lost his strong George and accents installing.
He was raised in an atmosphere of violence.
Gorrie was a rough town with organized street brawling being a popular pass
time.
On February the 13th 1892 the young stolen witnessed the public hanging of two
criminals.
The traumatized child came away with a hatred of the Cyrus regime style it,
and he was sent to a church school where he excelled academically.
He sang in the church choir and is impressed as teachers with his intelligence
and his memory.
In 1894 he graduated two years ahead of schedule.
Then at the age of 15 he was awarded a scholarship to the theology seminary in
tiff lists the Georgian capital.
However,
the team was more taken with the writings of Marx and Engels and the Bible
declaring himself a Marxist and an atheist.
He joins the Russian Social Democratic Labor Party or RSD LP.
In 1899 stolen was expelled from the seminary as a result of his Marxist
leanings.
By now.
He had adopted the revolutionary pseudonym Koba,
which was the name of George and Robin Hood type figure for the next two years.
He worked as a clerk at the titlist metrological observatory.
During this time he became involved in organizing strikes and writing articles
for Socialists newspapers.
He also became skills as making revolutionary speeches.
In 1901 he relocated to the and coastal town of Patou me.
Then he was encouraged by vrs DLP to start up on rest.
He helped to organize a strike in an oil refinery which led to him being in
prisons for this.
He spent 18 months in jail and was then deported to Siberia over the next 12
years.
Stalin,
he was arrested six times each time.
He managed to escape and returns the West often traveling on forged documents.
He was arrested for the final time in February of 1913 when was the exile to
Tara Hantske the most inhospitable part of Siberia.
He was there for four these years.
They hardened him and they made him cynical in 1986 stone in marriages.
First wife Carto is funny.
Z.
That's Sun Yaakov was born.
The following.
Yeah.
Stolen was often absent,
busy inciting unrest.
As a result,
his wife and sons or little of him can't say died of typhus in December of 1907
at the age of 22 there's a funeral stolen.
Declasse this creature softened my heart of stone.
She has died and it's wither have died.
My last warm feelings for humanity stolen,
ignored his son who was brought up by his in law in later years.
Stalin ordered the arrest and execution of much of caught his family,
including her brother Alexander,
who had introduced stolen Ricaurte in 1911 style and father to son by his lands
lady while living in a remote Georgia and village.
The by constant team never had any contact with his father.
In 1983 the RSD LP is split into two factions.
Bolshevik ans Menshevik stolen was an admirer of the writings of the revolution.
Vladimir Lenin,
and aligned himself with the Bolshevik cause,
his work to undermine the Mensheviks and his involvement in a number of
burglaries to raise funds for the Bolsheviks brought him to Lennon's attention.
Mm.
Lenin was impressed with Scotland calling him the wonderful Jordan.
In 1912 he appointed him to the Bolshevik Central Committee.
It was at this time that stolen drops is Georgia and alias Koba and took on the
name Stalin,
meaning man of steel.
The outbreak of war in 1914 accelerated the collapse of San Nicholas.
The second is rule to think on the eastern front,
sends the large loss of areas of territories,
Germany,
along with food shortages and economic hardship,
took its toll on Russia's fragile infrastructure.
Protests and strikes grew in intensity over the next three years and finally on
march the 15th 1917 the Russian parliament,
the Duma forced a provisional governance,
protests and strikes.
They grew in intensity.
Over the next three years.
Finally,
on march the 15th 1917 the Russian parliament,
the Duma formed a provisional government that same day saw Nicholas' abdicated
the 304 year Romanov Dynasty was that an ends a year later and ordered the
merger of the entire Romanov family,
the provisional government,
the socialist,
it's mainly the Mensheviks now ran the country.
The dual power was necessary as the government needed the support of the Soviets
who felt unprepared to take on full power Stalin.
He was still living in Siberia in x solid during the revolution.
He returns to live in Petrograd.
Well,
he took over the editorship of the Bolshevik newspaper profit,
which means truth.
The Bolsheviks were a minority party and stolen,
decided to cooperate with the provisional government in order to bolster the
parties popularity.
When Lenin returned from European exile,
he marched the revolution and it's condemned.
The new government has imperialistic and no better from the old regime.
He sends it stolen for his constellate acid.
You towards it.
As a result,
styling toughened his stance not only against the government,
it was against other socialist parties.
In July of 1917,
protests against the provisional government's broke out.
Leading Bolsheviks were arrested but not Stalin who was considered of listened
importance.
Stalin hid Lennon and helped him disappear into Finland in late October.
Then resends Patrick grads and,
uh,
just an immediate seizure of power.
However,
it moderates within the party advised restraint,
stolen,
surprisingly sided with them.
Then it however pressed on,
on October the 23rd amazing was health in which it was voted to undertake an
armed uprising.
Two days later,
the Bolsheviks armed wing led by Leon Trotsky took control of Petra grasp.
The provisional government was overthrown.
The Soviets had seized power lending,
instituted the new government,
the council of People's Commerce Arts Starlin was appointed the people's
commissar of nationalities across Russia.
Group's supposed to,
Lennon's new autocracy joined forces to remove the Bolshevik governments as the
Russians have war broke out.
Stalin was appointed a political commissar and it's put in charge of the defense
of the city of Sanford sin.
This is the city that would ultimately become Stalingrad.
He frequently clashed with Trotsky who had been appointed his military superior.
He wants him prison's a group of Trotsky supporters on a leaky bodge ans left
them to drown.
The Bolsheviks at this point changed their name to the Russian Communist Party.
Stalin's rise through this group's ranks was impressive and he owed it all to
the support of Lennon.
In 1922 Lennon made him general secretary of the Communist Party's central
committee,
a posty health.
For the rest of his life,
but within a year,
stolen had fallen out with Lennon,
Georgia.
It's Darlene's.
Home State had been promised autonomy at the time of the revolution,
but that promise had been reneges on between 1918 and 1921 it's an enjoyed a
period of self rule was in 1922 Lennon decided to bring us back into the fault.
He wants it the reunion to be a peaceful one,
but stolen.
He had other ideas.
He cracked down hot,
having the leaders of the George and rebellion execute it and then at this point
he was absolutely furious.
But in late 1922 he suffered the first of a series of strokes which severely
impacted his ability to command in its estimates,
which was published in November.
He castigated Stalin.
Stalin is too rude.
This defects becomes intolerable in a secretary general.
That is why I suggest the comrades.
Think of a way of removing stolen from that post and appointing another man in
his stat.
Months later,
while Lennon was still hospitalized style in that phone then and his wife,
who he suspected of feeding her husband's dislike event and subjected her to an
avalanche of abuse referring to her in the conversation as a syphilitic whore.
When Lennon found out about this,
he was unsurprisingly outraged.
Many people actually believe the stress of the situation precipitated Lennon's
death.
About 10 months later after Lennon's death,
Stalin took the lead in organizing the funeral,
the pairing as the chief pallbearer.
It was at this point that he initiated the deification of Lenin,
even renaming Petrograd as Lennon Grasp Stalin.
He used this opportunity to reinvent himself as the bearer of Lennon's legacy.
From now on to now,
Stalin was to doubt Lennon
stolons main rival was now Leon Trotsky and his followers.
The leftist Trotskyites in 1925 style enforced Trotsky to resign as people's
comments off a wall from now on,
anyone who spoke out against the secretary general worth risking their very
lives when open opposition broke out in late 1927 it's tremendous,
including Trotsky was expelled from the party.
Trotsky was exiled to Kazakhstan men.
1919 stolen,
married his second wife.
Now up,
they had two children,
Vaseline born in 1921 and fed liner,
born in 1926 on the evening of November the eighth 1932 the couple what?
Hosting a party to celebrate the 50th anniversary of the October Revolution.
They often argued,
and this occasion it was no difference and that edge,
the accused or husbands of being inconsiderate towards that,
he responded by humiliating her in front of their guests.
He flicked cigarettes a ta and to address her is,
hey you,
the following morning sevens found the Danish to dads have a gunshot wound to
the head during the rough and civil war,
Lenina daughter,
the acquisition of the peasants,
grain and livestock,
85% of the Soviet population,
they lived off the land.
He had also ordered the collectivization of farms.
Peasants perceived as better off the Kulaks were to be destroyed,
killed,
or to port it.
These measures caused widespread devastation and eventually famine
lines in his mistake.
Man In in 1921 introduced the new economic policy to try to improve the
situation.
However,
in 1928 style and decided to reintroduce collectivization,
he aims to achieve this.
Within five years,
anyone who was resisted was simply put to death.
In December of 1929 stolen announced the liquidation of the Kulaks as a class or
a peasants were encouraged to denounce the Kulaks who were to be shot on sight
or if they were lucky,
deported to gulags in Siberia.
Stalin sent out armed forces into the countryside to force villagers into
collectives.
Many of the people had no knowledge of agriculture.
The Q legs resulted to slaughtering their own cattle and destroying their own
equipment rather than see it disappear into the hands of the state.
Terrible famine.
Then in Syria and Ukraine,
it was the worst with up to 10 million people dying this time was to be
remembered as the killing of hunger.
Yeah.
At the state offered no help.
In fact,
anyone caught with so much as a handful of grain was liable to punishment by
death.
At the same time,
there's this,
people were starving to death,
stolen,
exported millions of tons of vitally needed grain in 1931 stolen stated that the
Soviet Union was a hundred years behind other countries.
Technologically,
they had 10 years to catch up or they would be crushed by the rest of the world.
His five year plan saw the birth of new industrial cities.
Within a decade.
The Soviet Union had indeed some hostile nations in terms of industrial
developments with the exception of the United States,
but ordinary Russians.
They fell a new benefit from stolen successes.
Factory workers became fixated on meeting unrealistic targets if they failed.
They risked the harshest of punishments.
By 1935 uh,
million citizens were residing in Stalin's forced labor camps.
The gulags at the 1934 political congress,
a threat to Stalin's absolute power in merged in the form of Leningrad Party
boss Sergei Kirov stolen,
reacted with a fierce purge of the party.
That's sort of 1,108 that's 56% of the congress delegates arrested and one third
of them execute it.
On September the first 1934 Sergei Kirov was assassinated outside the party
officer's in Leningrad,
the alleged assassin,
his wife and his 85 year old's mother will quickly put to death.
Though many people believe that Stalin himself was behind this assassination,
stolen,
seized upon this assassination as the catalyst for the great terror.
He brought in a new law which deprived of defendants have any defense.
A number of Moscow show trials were held nearly all of them resulting in the
death penalty over the next three years,
up to 1939 Stalin's purges became increasingly severe.
He did this for any methodically drawing up arrest quotas along with numbers to
be shot in each district still over fulfillments.
If this was encouraged,
people terrified of being denounced got in with their denunciations first before
the two words announced.
This led to the gulags soon being overcrowded and new complexes had to be built
by slave labor.
No one except for Stalin himself could Trudy and piece.
Many of those in positions of power became terrified that they too would be next
with some of them are committing suicide in order to do escape their fate.
The military,
we're not immune to the purchase either.
At the same time that Hitler was taking me over,
Austria stolen was ordering the execution of his most able military leaders,
those who survived and became paranoid of one another during 1939 is Hitler's
military muscle flexing pushed Europe towards war in feared for the safety of
his country.
He looks to Great Britain as a potential ally,
but prison didn't appear to be doing much of anything at all.
So when approached by Germany,
it stolen,
didn't hesitate.
He signs a nonaggression pact with Hitler.
It declared simply that the Russian and German people would not take up arms
against each other.
This took a great deal of pressure off stolen
and the summer of 1940 headless subjugation of Europe seemed unstoppable and
less than two weeks is blitzkrieg pans or armies had rolled through Belgium,
Holland,
and France.
And at this point he began looking to the east stolen.
However,
couldn't believe that the fewer up would go back on his word,
but on June the 22nd 1941 this is exactly what happens.
Nazi troops crossed the Polish border and invaded the Soviet Union.
The Soviet leader was caught totally off guard.
Within a month,
German troops were a hundred miles from Leningrad.
Smolensk fell on July the 16th ends.
By June the 26 just four days after the attack had begun,
400,000 Soviet soldiers were trapped as the German tenses and closed around
Minsk,
a key stronghold on route to Moscow.
On June the 29th reports reached Moscow that the city of mince could fallen.
It was only a week since the German invasion had begun.
At this rate,
the Germans expected to be in Moscow within a month.
It was at this point that stolen.
It seemed to finally grasp the enormity of the disaster.
He raged at his generals,
even reducing the stolid head of the army's Yaakov to tears,
but then stolen crumbles.
He grinds,
everything's lost.
I give up then and found it all Allstate and we've screwed it off.
Stolen was driven to his dodger on the outskirts of Moscow.
He slumped in shock in his arm chat the next day.
He didn't come into the Kremlin or responding to phone calls and as absence.
No one dared to make any decisions or sign any documents.
Suddenly there was a chilling vacuum at the heart of power.
Historians are divided on Stalin's mindset during this time.
Some believe that he was playing a dangerous game with is in a circle watching
and waiting to see who would try to seize the reins during this time of crisis.
Others are of the opinion that he gained close to a nervous breakdown.
What style in faced was not just military to feet,
but the collapse of everything that he had worked for within Russia.
Finally,
on June the 30th the politburo drove ounce to Stalin's dot.
Shah.
They found him still sitting in his arm.
Jack,
he looks up at them,
hi,
good and novice,
and he asked,
why have you come?
He suspected a COO,
but the politburo did not want to overthrow Stalin.
They wanted him to return to the Kremlin and take charge of the state.
Defense Committee.
The Soviet wall cabinets are relieved,
stolen,
perhaps that is most vulnerable ever asked,
can I leave the country to victory?
That may be more deserving candidates.
The reply though,
it came quickly.
There is none more worthy.
Nodding,
stolen,
accepted.
His new role as he began to regain has enough.
Kiev was overrun by September.
Stalin's advises had begged him to evacuate the deemed city.
However he refused and more than half a million people were either killed or
taken prisoner centrally for a scapegoat.
Stolen blames the prisoners themselves.
All prisoners of war he declared were traitors.
Those who resounds after the war were sent directly to labor camps when his son,
by his first marriage Yaakov was taken prisoner of the Nazis approached style
and about trading him for some of their own and Cynthia replied,
but he had no son by that name.
Yaakov was shot and killed by outside of the gym and sweat perilously close to
Moscow.
The government's moved 500 miles away,
but Stalin,
he decided to stay attending a parade on Red Square.
On November the seventh the tank strove Posten and onto the front lines just 25
miles outside of the city.
The Soviet troops fought valiantly and the Russian Windsor began to cripple the
German forces in the ends.
The Nazis were unable to solidify their gains and as they were steadily beaten
back,
stolen.
Also wisely teamed up with the allies will install in Churchill and Roosevelt.
Matt at the Toronto Conference in 1943 Joseph Stalin was reintroduced to the
west as kindly uncle Joe.
By 1945 the Soviets had won the war,
but the cost,
it was enormous.
More than 25 million Soviets had died six times as many as in Germany.
Stalin vowed that he would never let Russia be this vulnerable again of the
Yalta Conference.
In 1945 the allies match to discuss the postwar world.
Stalin made it clear that eastern Europe was to remain under his control,
Britain and the USA.
However,
we're not happy with Stalin's actions in eastern Europe.
Winston Churchill famously declared that an iron curtain had descended across
the continent and with that,
the Cold War began
back home.
Stalin was even more popular than before.
Grateful Russians hopes that the great victory overhead low would sweep clean
the misery of the past.
Unfortunately,
however,
the war had Millie distracted not to changed.
Joseph Stalin,
even though the crowds adored him,
he was convinced that everyone was out to get him.
Thousands of returning soldiers were sent to labor camps.
Many Jewish intellectuals and doctors were tried and killed on style.
The 70th birthday in 1949 images of the grades leader we're projected into the
skies over Moscow is all seeing eye was omnipresence,
but the ravages of old age.
We're beginning to catch up with him after a great feast.
On February the 28th of 1953 Joseph Stalin had a paralyzing stroke over the next
few days.
He slowly suffocated to death.
Joseph Stalin died on the morning of March the fifth 1953 his funeral was an
orgy of grief.
Soviet to simply couldn't imagine going on without their gaunt and father,
but go on.
They did three years after Stalin's death,
his eventual replacement,
Nikita Khrushchev gave an extraordinary speech at a closed session of the 20th
Party Congress.
He said that while Stalin had been a great leader,
he had also committed terrible crimes against the Soviet people.
The Myth of the benevolence protective comrade leader was finally reveals for
what?
It actually was a terrible lie.
So I really hope you enjoyed that episode of biographics.
If you did this,
a couple of things you could do right now.
One is hit that like button below.
Also,
if you want more stuff like this,
we put out brand new videos every Monday and every Thursday,
so hit that subscribe button below and subscribe button doesn't do what it used
to on Youtube.
If you actually want to get a notification about these videos,
please do hit that bell button next to the subscribe button and that'll send you
a notification every time,
every Monday and Thursday when we put out a new video.
Also,
if you want to watch something else right now,
stuff from the archive over there on the right,
and as always,
thank you for watching.